[Musique]
attention je vais faire quelque chose
histoire à tanger ans un manteau si
j'arrive à le récupérer avec ma bouche à
oreille pas tiré d'une sirène alors
récupéré avec ma bouche je double le
salaire de tous les chroniques euros et
ça peut être dangereux
[Applaudissements]
on a retrouvé quelques uns c'est
quelqu'un de ma famille qui a dix ans de
retard
elle a décidé de faire l'expérience qui
consiste à mettre des bonbons à la
menthe dans du coca de merde à la viola
pour la suite il pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait du cheval et du poney j'ai peur de
ça vous enlève la douleur mais ça marche
quand on a le feu au cul
[Applaudissements]
et alors j'ai perdu mon tél c'est pas
grave on s'est pas tenue il est dans mon
slip c'est vrai n'ont rien volé mon cas
[Applaudissements]
là c'est pas le coronavirus classé le
coronavirus vers hanoï les chefs des 10
commentaires sur les tenues toi ça va
pas du tout et de ces sauriens ont tiré
une [ __ ] sénécal aulas comme ça la
prochaine action climat de changer la
chaudière magnifique on dirait que tu
veux te marier
y'a plus qu'à trouver quelqu'un qui te
disent oui c'est un excellent boxeur
c'est vrai ça c'est vrai à rien c'est
pas mal ici l'agent me tu vas me
rajouter une cravate ta que tu fais là
que tu fais pas fini d'accord film
oblige et qui fait négliger on savait
les fonctions là ici la sueur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]